[Musique]
ckx pas à séoul
on ne peut échapper aux publicités
invitant à modifier son apparence
beaucoup de coréens considère la
chirurgie esthétique comme un préalable
indispensable à une carrière réussie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on prend si vous voulez y aller allez-y
si vous ne voulez pas n'y allez pas vous
pouvez porter ce que vous voulez en
dehors des tournages
si l'une de vous refuse de porter
quelque chose
cela veut dire qu'aucune de vous ne peut
le porter mais si l'une de vous portent
quelque chose ça ne veut pas dire que
vous allez vous habiller tout pareil ça
ne se fait pas d'accord nous sommes ici
pour travailler pour progresser au moins
un peu c'est dans notre intérêt à tous
yves guillemot
les employeurs accordent une attention
particulière à l'apparence des candidats
même le questionnaire standard dans
bausch contient une question sur leur
poids bonjour je suis zen je suis la
principale chanteuse de six bombes ravis
de faire connaissance vous avez
probablement compris que j'avais fait
une opération pour rendre ma silhouette
peu féminine
[Musique]
j'étais stagiaire pendant six ans
passant d'une entreprise à l'autre et
finalement j'ai décidé de tenter ma
chance une dernière fois et je me suis
retrouvé dans six bombes
cela fait trois ans que je travaille
avec
[Musique]
dan dah
notre groupe a des particularités qui le
distingue des autres notamment notre
apparence nous faisons beaucoup de
choses que les autres groupes féminins
ne font pas c'est pour ça que j'ai
rejoint le groupe avec enthousiasme nous
ne mettons pas l'accent sur une belle
apparence mais sur des chansons pleines
d'énergie
c'est un concept qui nous distingue
c'est un peu inhabituel pour un groupe
féminin quand on filme tous les défauts
de votre visage au sorte c'est
incontournable
je voulais vraiment faire de la
chirurgie esthétique parce que je
voulais que mon visage soit plus beau à
l'écran je voulais faire ça pour moi
même ma mère me dit de me marie le plus
tard possible et c'est ce que j'ai
l'intention de faire bien sûr un
travaillant avec le groupe je peux
rencontrer des gens bien comme des
hommes mauvais mais ma propre vie est
plus importante pour moi que le mariage
des enfants pour le moment mais les gars
[Musique]
nous devons tous savoir nous adapter
pour aller dans la même direction
autrement ce serait impossible parce que
c'est un travail en commun chacune de
vous à des amis vous êtes certes aussi
amis entre vous mais qu'est-ce que cela
signifie
vous avez à peu près le même âge mais
chacune de vous à ses propres amis et
vous vivez séparément c'est ça voilà
pourquoi il faut savoir s'adapter qui
sont arrivés plus tard devrait faire
plus d'efforts et répondre aux exigences
les parents offrent souvent leur fille
une opération de chirurgie esthétique à
la fin de leurs études sur la double
paupières pour agrandir les yeux secs
leçon bonjour je m'appelle lysol et je
suis chanteuse dans le groupe 6 bombes
oui je me suis fait opérer les yeux et
le nez j'étais heureuse de rejoindre un
groupe avec un tel concept
j'ai vraiment aimé l'idée en elle-même
et les membres du groupe
j'ai plein d'énergie c'est pourquoi
c'est facile de se lier d'amitié avec
moi au début je pensais que me faire
opérer et est une mauvaise chose mais
d'un autre côté ça aide à reprendre
confiance en soi
donc je me suis lancée en pensant que
j'aurais plus confiance en mes propres
capacités
quand ils ont vu mon visage modifié pour
la première fois ils se sont demandé qui
c'était
ça a été leur réaction mais quand j'ai
commencé à devenir plus joli en temps
ils se sont mis à dire ça te va si bien
tu es encore plus belle et puis ils sont
devenu jaloux
si vous voulez vous faire agrandir les
yeux faites le si vous voulez votre
balle redessiné faite le chacun doit
choisir son propre chemin
i know my name is right now la majeur op
[Musique]
nous ne serions peut-être jamais
rencontré si nous n'avions pas un
objectif commun l'essentiel pour nous ce
sont les affaires on n'est pas là pour
s'amuser ou se faire des amis vous
pouvez faire ça en dehors du travail
je ne vous appelle pas pour rien et ne
vous réunit pas sans raison je suis
votre producteur mais je ne vous appelle
pas pour vous embêter pendant votre
temps libre
je ne vous envoie pas de textos je ne
vous dérange pas mais quand nous sommes
ici ensemble on travaille bien sûr nous
passons beaucoup de temps ensemble nous
devons travailler ensemble pour
développer le groupe et gagner de
l'argent c'est notre objectif
[Musique]
en corée plus de 40 % des adolescents
interrogés ont reconnu rêvé de faire une
opération de chirurgie esthétique
bonjour à tous je m'appelle gabin je
suis membre de six bombes
j'ai 28 ans
[Musique]
j'ai fait du leap au feeling du
transfert de graisse pour améliorer le
contour de mon visage
[Musique]
normalement les groupes féminins essaie
de produire une impression de beauté
mais contrairement à eux six bombes à un
concept particulier comme ça a été le
cas avec la chanson white tennis belge
nous avons un concept qui nous
différencie des autres groupes féminins
de kpop encore et beaucoup de gens font
des opérations chirurgicales mais la
plupart des groupes
la plupart des gens ne l'admettent pas
ou même le cash je pense que ce serait
plus naturel de ne pas le taire d'en
parler honnêtement je fais de la danse
depuis longtemps voilà pourquoi par
rapport à d'autres participantes
bien sûr les autres s'entraînent
beaucoup et danse bien mais dans notre
groupe c'est moi qui suis responsable de
la danse l'un de nos fans des signes
vraiment bien chaque fois que nous le
voyons il nous offre ces dessins parfois
il me semble que rien n'a changé que mon
visage est resté le même mais quand je
me vois en photo ou dans une vidéo je
vois très bien que mes traits de visage
sont devenus plus expressif et à ces
moments là je me dis que je n'ai pas
fait de la chirurgie plastique pour rien
il ne faut pas se quereller ni essayer
de rabaisser quelqu'un du groupe
à quoi bon comment allez-vous travailler
ensemble si vous exposer tous vos
sentiments publiquement que le roux
bombarde et si personnellement vous
n'aimez pas quelque chose pas besoin de
me le dire de manière arrogante ne m'a
jamais rien de bon si nous avons un
accord nous devons tenir les promesses
que nous nous sommes fait si vous avez
des problèmes personnels
vous auriez dû le dire à l'avancé et ne
pas rejoindre le groupe qui n'a pas de
problèmes personnels
tout le monde en a mais tout le monde
essaie de s'adapter
[Musique]
presque tous les adolescents coréen rêve
de ressembler à leur idole du monde de
la kpop est c'est parti
bonjour je suis la leader de six bombes
la jolie sow a enchanté alors d'abord je
n'avais pas de paupières double je me
suis fait opérer et je fais un peu
modifié mon manteau j'y ai rajouté du
fils heures
[Musique]
nous voulons être sexy et nous voulons
faire de la chirurgie plastique par le
cadre de notre ambitieux concept nous
avons lancé un grand projet basé sur
notre désir de revenir sur scène moi
personnellement je me considérait déjà
comme bell mais après la chirurgie
plastique
j'ai l'impression d'avoir plus confiance
en moi je suis plus actives sur scène je
répète beaucoup je me réveille le matin
je me mets au travail je m'enregistre je
m'entraîne je rentre chez moi je regarde
la télé et je me couche
voilà
[Musique]
nous avons un emploi du temps très serré
même la nuit
qu'est ce que je suis je ne le sais même
pas comment pourrais-je me décrire je
peux endurer beaucoup je suis solide
[Musique]
on ne peut pas dire qu'une opération
fera de vous une chanteuse à succès mais
nous avons adopté ce concept après avoir
consulté les participantes et en effet
elle voulait se faire opérer voilà mais
au lieu de tout simplement faire de la
chirurgie plastique
nous avons décidé de l'allier au concept
du groupe parce que leur visage
changeront de toute façon après les
opérations notre entreprise et la
clinique de la chirurgie plastique ont
investi des sommes équivalentes
ils ont dit nous ferons la publicité et
le feront les opérations nous
continuerons à utiliser la chirurgie
plastique comme concept pour le groupe
et à faire la publicité de leurs
cliniques
nous sommes donc mis d'accord et avons
commencé à travailler ensemble
toutes les participantes ont accepté les
conditions proposées en signant le
contrat
ai-je besoin encore de faire quelque
chose ce serait bien de relever un peu
les sourcils pour être dessus de
l'arcade ce serait bien de le faire tout
commentaire
et c'est quoi cette opération vous voyez
ici la ligne des sourcils et un peu en
dessous de la ligne de l'os faisais et
les sourcils doivent être ici en tout
cas ce serait mieux les yeux on ne
touche pas mais ils sont parfaits
[Musique]
ah ah
au moment